fne couleur chair davis temps une fois
le camion de pompier vadot quitté ville
perdue car les établissements dufresne
ont décidé de se séparer de 400 pièces
parmi elles des machines agricoles des
camions et même son mythique
hélicoptères bananes des engins qui font
partie de la collection de maurice
dufresne le mythique ferrailleurs et une
moissonneuse que j'ai reconnu fil des
années ils ont 50 55 parfois j'ai
reconnu je leur ai vu fonctionner durant
60 ans maurice dufresne aujourd'hui
décédé a acquis des engins venus des
quatre coins de l'europe du matériel et
des pièces que les amoureux de
patrimoine industriel et s'arrache il ya
un belge laquelle à cacheter anc a déjà
acheté une vingtaine de lots en
commençant par les les camions de 14-18
qu'on fait entre 2005 et 3000 euros et
les donne en gt3 et puis après l'achète
touski machinisme agricole
un peu pointu un collectionneur belge à
droite de notre image et autour de lui
une demi douzaine d'acheteurs
ils veulent tous la même chose le lot
327 une épave
oui mais celle d'un tracteur renault à
chenilles fabriqués sur le modèle des
chars de la première guerre et si vous
restez jusqu'à tout à l'heure vous allez
voir que les gens sont capables de
mettre beaucoup d'argent éventuellement
pour quelque chose qui est tout roule et
oui c'est la plus belle vente de ces
enchères
lovely l'euro pour le tracteur à
chenilles a pu partir à doc en belgique
l'hélicoptère banane lui restera en
touraine
la mise à prix de 8000 euros n'a pas été
renchéri